Elle est si belle pour moi, les gens viennent ici
Ils n'ont aucune excuse pour l'avenir
après ce tourisme détruit
Si vous attendez des gens, je pense que c'est un
ils ne viennent pas chaque semaine, les touristes ne viennent pas ici
a raison de venir
mais je leur donne du crédit
Le turc sait qu'il a une histoire de 13 jours
Si vous ne le voyez pas, si vous venez pour la date
Que se passera-t-il après la fin de l'histoire?
Ça n'a pas de sens donc ici de l'Islam
Si je fais tout ce qu'ils ont fait quotidiennement, tu le sais
le moment est ici vieux journal jamais parti je dis
Pas l'argent à trois faces, donc les deux messages
Je lançais et vendais des cadeaux
j'ai gagné je lançais du café juteux
tout de la crème glacée se vendait ici
Pas d'électricité pour nous pour le moment, article différent
écrivons-nous
s'abonner